[Musique]
le trio qui cartonnait en france d'abord
celle et oublie free c'est en 96 to be
free filip nikolic adel et franck bien
entendu et c'était un succès énorme
comment on fait pour passer d'un succès
incroyable des beatles c'était les
bilans des c'est vrai mais c'est normal
non non non non c'est normal après ce
qu'on pète pas un art mais en fait
l'avantagé qu'on avait c'est que nous
contrairement à d'autres groupes ont été
des potes d'enfance donc du coin c'est
ça c'est de rester soudés grâce à ça
ouais nous éviter un peu de péter les
plombs entre guillemets et puis dont
vivent et notre aventure enfin on était
des potes d'enfance qui vivait un conte
de fées il ya eu un drame normes il ya
eu un drame
en 2009 le drame qui nous a tous marqués
c'est évidemment le décès de philippe
quand vous avez vu philippe repartir
qu'est ce que vous aviez vous êtes dit
peut-être ça a été on a eu tellement de
succès avant qu'après c'est peut-être ça
qui a fait que il n'a pas pu se remettre
de l'énorme succès avant toute chose moi
je n'avais pas de contact avec philippe
pratiquement huit mois avant qu'il soit
parti d'accord il ya j'entendais des
bruits comme quoi ça n'allait pas et
puis voilà c'est qu'il sait permet
bronzé qui était angoissé et qui
inquiète c'était un extrême sur tout ce
qui faisait donc il faisait pas les
choses à moitié quand il fait quelque
chose
voilà c'était le coup de trop le soir
aussi les parties c'était à la fois de
trop il ya rudy les poetic lover moi je
me rappelle des politiques lover c'est
vrai que j'adorais ce groupe
rudy comment ça se passe parce que c'est
vrai que tout le monde se demande c'est
vrai que ça a été aussi c'est un énorme
carton aller poetic lover
comment ça se passe là prêt quand on
sent que ça ça voilà que vous vous étiez
préparé à ça ou pas vous êtes marrants
du tout ouais du tout du tout ça et
qu'on était des gosses qui rêvait dans
leur quartier ouais ça regardait
l'émission graines de star comme on a dû
tout à l'heure qui était un peu le
redire l'ancêtre du télé crochet on va
dire bien sûr et on rêvait de tout
simplement passé dans cette émission qui
on a eu l'occaz et à partir de là je
peux rien te dire ça a été trop rapide
quoi comment ça c'est comment ça s'est
fini les politiques lover en fait on a
fini par s'embrouiller assez certain
moment ouais tu mets les filles
l'oseille la notoriété réac assadiq
s'est réveillé
[Rires]
ça ou ça oui mais juste est le point
commun entre tous les groupes qu'ils
sont ils se sont arrêtés mais très
rapidement en même temps que ses idées
mais trois quatre mois tous ça a été
étonnant crise des déchets soit c'est un
énorme roue puis c'est normal après
j'étais comme un ouf sur vous et premier
boys band des escouades et est donc vous
aussi c'est un énorme carton wavy très
gros et très rapide c'est ça qui a été
le plus étonnant c'est à dire ça ou pas
on vous a dit vous allez dès dimanche tu
as alors non bien évidemment personne ne
s'attend à ça vraiment mais les
producteurs ils n'ont pas senti tout de
suite non non non moi j'étais un peu
préparé parce que j'ai dans un autre
boss bande à van avant mon service
militaire mais mais du coup non on se
prépare pas à cette fulgurance et vous
comment ça s'est fini coller les défis
squatts à s'effilocher un espèce de truc
un peu voilà filandreux